hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
lektion 16 hört zu und spricht nach
als was arbeitest du als was arbeitest
du ich arbeite als koch ich arbeite als
koch was ist dein beruf
was ist dein beruf mein beruf ist
informatiker mein beruf ist informatiker
was bist du von beruf was bist du von
beruf ich bin lehrer
ich bin lehrer was ist dein job
was ist dein job ich bin bauarbeiter ich
bin bauarbeiter als
wald verdient man viel geld als anwalt
verdient man viel geld als bäcker muss
man früher aufstehen als bäcker muss man
früh aufstehen als arzt muss man lang
studieren als arzt muss man lang
studieren
ich bin student ich bin student ich
studiere medizin
ich studiere medizin
mein name
ist paul schneider
ich wohne in olten
und bin 39 jahre alt ich bin geschieden
und habe eine tochter
sie ist 14 jahre alt
und wohnt bei ihrer mutter
was machen sie beruflich
ich bin informatiker ich habe immer
viele aufträge
was ist schwierig am beruf informatiker
als informatiker muss man immer wieder
neues lernen
die technik verändert sich ständig und
schnell
man muss immer up to date bleiben und
die neue hardware und software kaufen
und lernen
sie sind selbstständig was gibt es dafür
vor und nachteile
mir gefällt es selbstständig zu sein
selbstständig sein bedeutet dass ich
mein eigener chef bin
es bedeutet aber auch viel verantwortung
und arbeit
oft muss sich am abend oder am
wochenende arbeiten
wenn ich ein projekt oder einen auftrag
erledigen muss
dann habe ich oft sehr lange
arbeitszeiten
das ist anstrengend aber ich mache das
ja für mich und mein portmonee
guten tag frau koller stellen sie sich
bitte vor
guten tag mein name ist heike kohler und
ich bin 32 jahre alt
ich bin deutscher und lebe seit vier
jahren in der schweiz
ich bin single und habe keine kinder
was ist ihre arbeit frau koller
ich arbeite als ärztin in einem
krankenhaus in winterthur
wie ist die arbeit als ärztin mein beruf
gefällt mir sehr
ich kann menschen helfen
und manchmal hätte ich sogar leben
als ärztin verdiene ich viel geld
uns gibt es auch etwas negatives an
ihrem beruf
ja ich finde die arbeitszeit negativ
ich muss immer für einen notfall bereit
sein wenn ich notfalldienst habe kann
jeden moment das handy klingelt
und ich muss sofort ins spital gehen
man muss lange an der universität
studieren um ärztin zu werden
was machen sie beruflich
im moment arbeite ich als bauarbeiter
ich arbeite bei der ausbau ag
die arbeit ist sehr abwechslungsreich
gibt es auch eine negative seite
die arbeitszeiten sind lang
ich arbeite meistens neun stunden pro
tag
und am abend bin ich dann total müde
ich arbeite als bäckerin beide bäckerei
brötchen und co
wie lange arbeiten sie schon als
bäckerin
ich arbeite schon seit 20 jahren als
bäckerin 20 jahre sind eine lange zeit
macht ihnen der beruf immer noch spaß
ja sicher beschreiben sie bitte den
beruf bäckerin für unsere zuhörer
wie sieht ein typischer arbeitstag in
der bäckerei aus am morgen stehe ich
sehr früh auf
meistens fängt die arbeit um 4 uhr an
dann packen wir die brote und kuchen
oder bereiten die sandwiches und canapés
vor
die bäckerei macht um 6 uhr auf was ist
positiv und was negativ an ihrem beruf
positiv finde ich die abwechslung
zwischen backen und verkaufen negativ
finde ich den lohn
ich verdiene als bäckerin nicht so viel
habe also einen tiefen lohn
ich muss arbeiten ich muss arbeiten
ich muss heute noch arbeiten
ich muss heute noch lange arbeiten
ich muss die wäsche waschen
ich muss die wäsche waschen du musst die
kleiderbügeln du musst die kleiderbügeln
er muss das geschirr abwaschen
die lebensmittel einkaufen wir müssen
die lebensmittel einkaufen
ihr müsst den müll rausbringen
sie müssen die wohnung putzen sie müssen
die wohnung putzen